upstairs our goal is to help heart get
back to us any ideas huh
wait if i remember correctly the rooms
in our shop move around
oh yeah we should stop them
done okay so now that's taken care of
what do we do huh uh first we'll need a
map of the shop ah yes yes we do so that
is job one get a map of the shop
next we should find heart on the map
yeah we should so that'll be job two
figure out where hart is on the map then
we need to find ourselves and i mean on
a map none of this backpacking through
europe after graduation business huh
uh
never mind okay well uh job three figure
out where we are on the map yes and once
we do all that then last tell heart how
to get from there to here so job one get
a map of the shop let's do it oh huh i
have a map on this tablet that shows
where the room stopped look
perfect fantastic get a map of the shop
check
one job done three more to go yeah
there's the horn room
find out where heart is on the map
check and here we are at the counter
where the customers sit figure out where
we are
check
three jobs done one more to go
look at us getting it done here okay so
uh heart is there
and we are here
i think i see a path
[Music]
that is the best one
i found a way back i'm gonna give you
commands okay ready ready commander cody
all right
first open the door
i am opening the door
next walk forward through the room then
open the other door i am walking forward
and opening the other door
all right then walk forward again i am
walking forward again
great
cody you did it
[Music]
heart is in the kitchen right here
it's empty
where's heart heart where are you
i am in the clouds
[Music]
you're up in the sky
no it is a room filled with clouds
it is very beautiful there's the cloud
room right here but how'd heart get
there
i see what happened
heart went forward through two doors
just like you said
but instead of heart going this way
heart went
that way ah
oh i am so sorry heart i should have
been clearer with my instructions
there's more than one door in each room
and we need to make sure you're going in
the right direction oh how about we tell
hart which room to go in next oh that's
a great idea buddy bud nope i see a
different path to get heart back to us
look here heart should go this way
hot open the door to the stinky cheese
room
[Music]
excellent now walk forward through the
stinky cheese room
no
what do you mean no
you're just too stinky
well i know that it's stinky it's the
stinky cheese room i will not go that
way thank you for your time
but but that is the path the path is the
path is the path is the path oh frumpled
curtains no no mr prim i see another way
all right hearts listen to me and listen
good i know you've been through a lot
today
not really it's been pretty nice
actually
oh okay
i forgot what i was doing
helping heart get back
[Music]
all right
first
find the blue room
and walk forward into it
i am in the blue room i found it on my
first try oh great
next command find the glow in the dark
room and walk forward into that
okay
i am in the glow in the dark room
next command find the door to the jungle
room and walk forward into it
okay i am in the jungle room
last command walk forward through the
jungle room and open the door
[Music]
oh
[Music]